now to the fight over abortion and a new
law passed in oklahoma that is now the
most restrictive abortion law in this
country
oklahoma is one of 26 states that are
certain or likely to ban abortion if the
supreme court allows it that's according
to a leading abortion rights group jan
crawford covers as it covers the supreme
court for us and jan what does this new
oklahoma law say because either
depending on your point of view you're
either very concerned or you're cheering
well that's the whole issue of abortion
right it's so divisive and this law of
course would prohibit abortion at any
point in pregnancy except to save a
woman's life or in the case of rape or
incest and they are only if it's
reported to law enforcement it would
take effect immediately after governor
kevin stitt signs it which he has said
he will do it will go further than this
similar texas law which bans abortion as
early as six weeks and gives private
citizens the right to enforce it by
suing abortion providers now that texas
law is in effect while it's being
challenged in court and that has caused
some texas women to seek abortions in
oklahoma oklahoma closed that door
though earlier this month when it
enacted its own six weeks ban so this
latest legislation now it goes even
further it says abortion is banned any
time after fertilization emergency
contraception though the so-called
morning-after pill that would not be
affected now other states like indiana
and nebraska they're considering similar
laws all of this of course anticipating
that the supreme court will overturn roe
vs wade this summer and allow each state
to set its own abortion policy nate
jan thank you